so being from Dallas you're like a
Cowboys guy yeah yeah I wish I wasn't
but I have to Mavericks yeah of course I
mean Luca you know because that's fun to
root for the Cowboys 28 years of just
for tell everybody
yeah yeah dude it's so funny to watch
because I still listen to a sports radio
station in Dallas till this day I mean
I'm from Phoenix so that's what I do I
listen to my local station on TuneIn and
then yeah that's that all I care about
is Arizona Sports I don't give a [ __ ]
about the Lakers or I'm sure you don't
care about the Yankees or anything no I
truly don't the next being bad is funny
to me right like I would I would like to
be here when they're good because you
right because you're a basketball fan
yeah when Sandy happened you could feel
it right right right right right by
energy I don't normally feel it but when
the sanity was happening you could feel
the whole city buzzing yeah so if the
Knicks were good good which they might
be uh that'd be fun but generally
speaking I think it's funny to watch an
expanse suffer so you were here during
the insanity moment yeah yeah yeah and
that was as close to an Indian
basketball players we'd ever had so
always hype right so yeah yeah that's my
guy you you guys have never had a NBA
player ever no well we had sadnam Singh
who's in the D league right the gas
Punjabi dude like seven three one speaks
English but you guys do have the uh
what's the name of the wrestler uh the
great uh the great Khalid he's he's we
also have oh my God I can't believe this
guy's I don't remember this guy's name
he follows me on Twitter I've hung out
with him what is his name Jinder Mahal
Jinder Mahal yeah yeah I'm a big
wrestling guy dude yo my badge in there
shout out to gender I hung out with him
in Tampa before nice guys dude this guy
definitely on steroids he he tells me
he's not but I'm like it's okay yeah he
went from being like kind of a chubby
bigger dude he got fired and then he
bounced back and he was [ __ ] shredded
like a Mania I'm like yo this guy's six
months the craziest turn around steroids
are serious his shoulders are nuts yeah